the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
tonight on politics now nevada starts
the process of
kissing the caucus goodbye and saying
hello to a first in the nation
presidential primary plus i think it's
important that
you know we all do our part to get the
public back into this building
republicans lay out their priorities in
the legislature
including a bill dealing with absentee
ballots and
there's still a lot of confusion and
unknown answers
some clark county kids are heading back
to class
one principal shows us how she's trying
to keep her school safe
from eight news now this is politics now
the legislative session is slowly but
surely getting underway
and the bill to get rid of nevada's
caucus and make our primary the first in
the country
is finally written thanks for joining us
i'm vanessa murphy and for john langler
this week
it is one of several election related
bills assembly bill 126 was introduced
by speaker jason fryerson
it would move nevada to a primary and it
would also set the primary in late
january making us
the first in the nation the movement to
change to a primary gain traction one
year ago
after the problems with the iowa caucus
nevada democrats also tried a type of
ranked choice voting in the 2020 caucus
where you list your
top three or five candidates unlv
political science associate professor
rebecca gill says
incorporating that would open up the
choice landscape for voters
all of us you know we kind of have a
candidate that we might feel
closest to who is the one we really
really really want to win
but then we might second-guess ourselves
and we get into
well is this person really going to be
electable and these kinds of questions
and so it can
lead voters to actually
cast a vote for their second favorite
choice or something like that because
they think that that's what everybody
else is going to do
and if they were to vote for their real
first choice
then it would be essentially a wasted
vote because
they might end up with their least
favorite choice um but when you do
ranked voting what this does is it
essentially takes
that part of the strategy
sort of off of the voter's plate a
separate bill put forward by republicans
senate bill 121 would switch nevada to
open primaries
right now we have a closed primary
meaning only republicans can vote for
a republican presidential candidate and
only democrats for
a democrat it is sponsored by republican
state senator ben kikefor
who points out that about a third of
nevada's voters are registered as
nonpartisan and left out of the process
in our current system
the most commented on and controversial
bill so far in the legislature
might catch you a little by surprise
it's a proposed change to your child's
school curriculum
the word government is taken out of
education requirements
civics financial literacy and
multicultural education
are added in this bill has had more
opinions submitted than
any other so far with nearly thirteen
hundred almost
all of those were in opposition to it a
lot of that response is from parents who
homeschool
their children and say this plan
shouldn't apply to them
committee members say the bill is meant
as a way to clarify the law
i think that there might be some uh
misrepresentation out there and
and i'm gonna assume that it's benign um
that government is now being replaced by
multicultural education i can
100 percent tell you that is that is not
the case civics
will encompass government those in
support of the bill say
more multicultural education needs to be
happening
in our schools with no in-person
appearances allowed submitting your
opinion online
is one of a few avenues to get voices
heard
here are the other most commented on
bills ab19 had more than 1300 opinions
submitted
second was the bill with a bunch of
unemployment program
fixes with nearly 300 and third was a
bill that establishes a dark sky
designation for certain parts of the
state
that one is promoted by the sierra club
and other
environmental groups the fourth most
commented on bill would temporarily
suspend parts of teacher evaluations
assembly bill 157 is sponsored by the
assembly committee on education
15 of a teacher or administrator's
evaluation
is based on pupil growth this would
suspend that part until the 2023 school
year
it had its first hearing this week
so can republicans get any of their
priorities through
my i-team colleague david charns
interviewed assembly deputy minority
floor leader tom roberts
about the state of the session an
election reform bill he's
sponsored and also about that potential
primary move
the beginning of this this session has
been slow
um you know people aren't in the
building the you know the
the hearings are the phone calling in
and you know the technology is great in
one aspect but it's hard to you know
really hear from people and see people
um
so when do you expect things to really
start picking up
bill drafting has been kind of uh behind
i you know uh typically we're hearing a
lot more bills
uh earlier uh than we are now
um so they extended the deadline for
introductions for two weeks because of
that
so it should start picking up uh
you know fairly quickly we've introduced
a number of bills over the last
a couple of floor sessions we did not
have a floor session today
i think we're up to maybe 150 bills that
have been introduced on our side
alone and i don't know where they're at
on the senate
uh with that said so those those are
being referred to committees and
committees are starting to
schedule hearings so it should pick up
ab134 which is
uh about absentee ballots um
about you'd have to request an absentee
ballot it wouldn't automatically be sent
to you
obviously in response to ab4 during the
special session
um is is this needed election reform in
terms of you should request a ballot
then automatically
be sent one i think there's some
safeguards in place
with uh requesting a ballot um
you know with absentee ballots i think
there's it during
obviously during the the early parts of
the pandemic
uh you know mail-in ballots were sent
out and there's been some challenges
with people getting multiple ballots
i think there were some challenges with
removing voters from the rolls
so we we sent a lot of ballots out that
didn't necessarily need to be
sent out uh you know just from uh
economic standpoint i think that's a
challenge
uh so i think we need to clean some of
those things up
uh i you know i i don't mind
mailing ballots i'm not afraid of
mail-in ballots i think there's some
challenges with
uh which with ballot harvesting with
people collecting ballots
there is a move to make nevada the first
in the nation primary state
get rid of caucuses uh which
is one thing but then not only move to
primaries
but make us the first state
to to do that obviously
uh there's being the first is
is debatable but should we move to
primaries
well look i i've participated in
caucuses before
um and i'll tell you i wasn't a big fan
of it
i i i like primaries better
um you know and i i think
a majority of my constituents that have
reached out to me
prefer prefer primaries i think the
challenge you have
is you know is i don't i don't believe
that we should hold
two separate primaries right um
you know if we could move the regular
primary process
back to you know to where we're first in
the west
you know roll everything back you know i
think that's that's doable
yeah i think the challenge is that you
know there's every state is trying to be
the first
i think it's important that uh you know
we all do our part to get
the public back into this building uh we
need to get our kids back in school
uh we need to get our kids back to
playing sports and you know and
uh we've been hunkered down too long and
and i think nevadans have done their
part and i think we need to start
moving back to some some kind of
normalcy
robert said vaccinations start next week
that will help efforts to get the public
back in the legislative building
separately a group of
republican lobbyists have filed a
federal lawsuit saying keeping them
out of the legislative building is
unconstitutional
the attorney has been on several of the
lawsuits against governor
steve sisilak's executive orders the
latest
states that keeping them out of the
building stops them from engaging in
constitutionally protected
lobbying activities and quashes the
spirit of the legislative process
the lobbyists include janine hansen and
melissa clement
a few more of the criminal justice and
police reform bills have been written
this week
assembly bill 1577 seems targeted at
incidents like the one in central park
last year where a white woman called
police on a black man
simply because he told her to put a
leash on her dog
the nevada bill would allow people to
sue someone for calling the police on an
individual because of their race gender
identity or other protected classes
specifically if the person knowingly
causes law enforcement to respond to a
location to
harass embarrass humiliate or remove
someone
no hearing is scheduled yet we're about
a week away from some students returning
to classrooms in clark county
it will be hybrid learning a mix of in
person and online
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us what one principal is doing to
try to keep classrooms clean and
safe don darrow elementary school
gets ready to welcome back students
pictures show a and b stickers on desk
to designate the cohort
marking where students sit six feet
apart depending on the day in class
on the playground colorful markers with
the dolphin mascot indicate
social distancing staff will give each
student a backpack to carry their
computer between home
and the classroom each child will also
receive supplies
specifically for their desk but don't
expect
this at all campuses each school has
different needs based on the population
they serve
and they obviously are going to be
prepared for that ryan lewis is
principal at gerheim elementary school
he says collaboration continues among
his colleagues
kind of vetting out procedures having
ideas
troubleshooting as things come arise he
remains mindful of the fourth and fifth
graders unable to start hybrid learning
yet
he submitted a plan to bring voluntary
small groups on campus we are ready to
be able to invite those kids back when
we're given the green light to do so
and and give them the attention they
deserve as well there's still a lot of
confusion and unknown answers
rebecca garcia questions the lack of
consistency
the nevada parent teacher association
president tells me some students already
came back for tutoring
while others continue waiting very
little reassurance from the district
about how equity is going to be insured
for all students
kristin drummond 8 news now
some teachers will be back in the
classroom starting monday
to prepare for march 1st controversy
over the airport the look at the
unanimous decision by the clark county
commission to change the name of
mccarran
welcome back to politics now
the southern nevada health district did
not get its shipment of moderna vaccine
doses this week
anyone expecting their second moderna
dose will be rescheduled to next week
and those 65 and older will be eligible
to get the vaccine next week at
pharmacies
that's on top of nevada already
receiving a low
amount of the vaccine we are second to
last in the number of vaccines per
capita oracle mana has more on the
effort to get vaccines into seniors arms
we're finally going to be able to go
outside
and not fear dying 66-year-old shirley
bryce is thrilled that nevadans age 65
to 69 can get the covet 19 vaccine
starting next week
she's been fighting for this moment even
creating an online petition
little late but certainly we're thrilled
with governor sisselok and his team
they listen to our concerns and they're
taking action
but those seniors will only be able to
get the vaccine at pharmacy partners for
right now and the supply is limited
we know it will not be enough to cover
the range of the values in this atrium
we continue to ask the nevadas to be
patient
as we await increased allocations from
the federal government
the goal is to expand vaccination events
for those 65 and older by march first
meanwhile the governor is in constant
contact with the white house to get more
vaccines
we're getting the vaccines that we get
into people's eyes
and although a lot is still uncertain
nevada seniors say one thing is clear
at least we see motion and vaccinating
our age group
we have a lot of vaccine related links
at eightnewsnow.com
to help you one of the more
controversial topics this week
the clark county commission voted
unanimously to change the name of the
airport
from mccarran to harry reid
i believe it's kind of a political move
uh to put
senator reid's name on it if you're
really concerned
about senator mccarron and some things
that he might have done
well okay then call it the las vegas
metropolitan airport
he isn't a man of many words but of
profound words when meeting him in 2005
he spoke about the growing latino
community in a way i had not heard in
nevada
the name change was pushed by county
commissioner tick sagar bloom
then pretty much every democratic
politician in the state endorsed the
idea
a few republicans like former governor
brian sandoval did as well
there was not a lot of opposition to
removing mccarran's name but
much of the public was in favor of
renaming it las vegas
international airport in fact las vegas
international
airport was trending on twitter for two
straight days
our poll last week showed about three
quarters of people opposed
naming it after reid the next step is
submitting the plan to the faa
that will take at least a few months to
go through sega bloom says
it will be funded by private donations
one of the youngest members of the
legislature ever
i've been welcomed by the republican
side pretty warmly
up next we hear from 24 year old state
senator and public health professional
fabian donate
you're watching politics now
president joe biden says he wants
congress to pass a sweeping immigration
reform bill
on thursday democrats introduced a bill
to try to make that a reality
our washington dc correspondent
alexandra limon breaks it down for us
on thursday democratic lawmakers
introduced the u.s citizenship act
president joe biden's vision for
immigration reform with a path to
citizenship for dreamers and other
undocumented immigrants
they pick our fruit they pack our meat
they keep our food supply strong
even in times of crisis like this
pandemic
they are essential workers so essential
that our economy would not function
without them
new jersey senator bob menendez and
california congresswoman linda sanchez
say the bill will help the u.s economy
grow
we'll increase worker productivity
create more jobs
improve the wages of all workers and
reduce our deficit
and if you don't believe me just ask any
economist
to get through congress the bill would
need support from 60 senators
a challenge considering some republicans
are already expressing opposition
in a statement republican senator rick
scott said
granting amnesty to 11 million illegal
immigrants
on a timeline quicker than any major
legislation offered in recent history
without including any funding whatsoever
to enhance border security
is reckless and would fuel a
never-ending cycle of illegal
immigration
democrats say their bill will modernize
and improve
border security and address the root
causes of immigration from central
america
in washington alexandra limon
one of the newest members of the nevada
legislature is also one of the youngest
ever state senator fabian danate is just
24 years old but already works in public
health
he's a democrat and was appointed to
replace ivana concello when she left
christian casadis has been interviewing
members of the hispanic legislative
caucus for us and
this week talked with state senator
danate
seeing the folks the republican side
there
just seeing how that you're going to
have to work with them
you know to get things done here um what
are some of the challenges what
you know what are you kind of seeing
here uh moving forward
i've been welcomed by the republican
side uh pretty warmly
they have been receptive to some of the
issues i have brought forth before them
i think that they understand the
jeopardy that our state is in right now
because of this public health crisis
and given my background in public health
they have been
understanding to some of the issues that
i'm trying to push forward
public health usually gets politicized
in some circumstances but for the most
part we're all fighting for the same
thing which is
to make sure that everyone is back to
their regular health that
we can reopen our schools and our
economies stabilize
anything kind of mapped out for the next
uh
few weeks or months yeah so my
legislation is going to prioritize
trying to fix and get us on the right
track
to solve this pandemic as have i as
i have already documented is that there
are
a lot of problems that stand in our way
to making sure that we
reach the threshold of making uh bring
everything back to normal
right now the greatest concern that we
have at this moment in time
is making sure that our communities are
vaccinated
and that we increase health literacy
which is the people actually understand
the information that is being received
to them
so the legislation that i want to put
forward is to increase uh
to allow employers for them to
pay their employees to get tested and
vaccinated so that they don't have to
worry about taking time off
to do that and any of the lost wages
that they might not be able to
recuperate that is going to be one of
the things that i try to entertain
within the next
few months and also expanding
translational services because as we
know
just not everyone has the ability to
speak in english within the state
and if we're able to communicate better
as to some of the outcomes of what can
be achieved through this vaccine
then we can start to fix a lot of the
public health issues that we are
recognizing right now at this moment
because of the pandemic
donate also said he wants to carry on
some of the priorities of his
predecessor ivana cancella
that includes pushing for drug pricing
transparency and bills that address
climate change